you may already be familiar with
Coulomb's law which is really the most
important or underlying law behind all
of what we know about electrostatics and
how things with charge attract or
repulse each other but a simplified
version of Coulomb's law is just that
the force between charged particles the
magnitude of the force is going to be
proportional to the product of the
charges so Q one would be the charge of
one of the charged particles maybe this
is an ion Q two would be the charge of
the other particle maybe that's an ion
divided by R squared and if we're
talking about ions R is going to be the
distance between their nuclei and if the
charges are different it's going to be a
force of attraction if the charges are
the same it's going to be a force of
repulsion and we can use Coulomb's law
to think about ionic compounds so let's
go with maybe the most common ionic
compound in our daily life and that is
table salt table salt is sodium chloride
so sodium chloride we have talked about
this in other videos it is made up of
positively charged sodium cations so you
have an na plus so sodium is a group one
element it's very easy to nab an
electron off of it and then it has a
positive charge and it's made up of a
chloride anion so CL minus chloride is a
group seven element it really wants to
get that extra electron to have eight
valence electrons in its outermost shell
and so it's very likely to Glac grab an
electron maybe from a sodium and so
these two characters are going to be
attracted to each other notice they have
opposite charges and when you have a
bunch of sodium and chloride together
you'll have a structure that looks
something like this and in chemistry we
call this a lattice now in everyday
language you might associate things like
lattices with
kind of a crossing pattern like that and
in chemistry where we're talking about a
lattice we're talking about a
three-dimensional structure of atoms or
three-dimensional structure of ions that
have a repeating pattern to them and you
could see that here in future videos
we'll go into more detail on two lattice
structures but you can see in this
picture the Purple's are the sodium
cations and the greens are the chloride
anions and the reason why the sodium
cations are so small you can see that if
you look at the periodic table of
elements here we have said that as you
go to the right your radius decreases
but what's happening is when sodium
loses that outermost electron then it's
electrons have a noble gas configuration
of neon so it really loses that third
shell it gets smaller and not only does
it lose that third shell but it has 11
protons so it's going to have a very
strong pull on those electrons in that
second shell and similarly chloride is
going to gain an electron so it's going
to have a noble gas configuration of
argon so it is going to be bigger now
when we talked about covalent bonds we
talked about the bond energy the energy
needed to pull apart the atoms that were
forming the covalent bonds there's a
similar notion for ionic bonds like this
and that is lattice energy and that is
the energy necessary to pull the ions
apart so that they are infinitely far
apart from each other and lattice energy
is usually measured in kilojoules per
mole which is also what we measure bond
energy and because they're really the
same notion except lattice energy you're
breaking up a lattice of ions well in
bond energy you're normally talking
about covalent bonds now I want you to
think about something what's going to
have a higher lattice energy would it be
sodium chloride or let's pick something
else let's say we had rubidium rubidium
chloride which is going to have a higher
lattice energy what's
going to take more energy to pull the
ions apart and I'll give you a hint
with this periodic table of elements all
right well rubidium chloride that's made
up instead of a sodium cation that's
made up of a rubidium cation so you have
our b-plus and of course you have the
chloride anion CL minus and so what's
the difference here the anion is both
chloride in both cases but when you look
at rubidium vs. sodium rubidium when it
loses an electron is going to have a
noble gas structure electron structure
of Krypton while sodium once it loses an
electron is its electron it's electron
configuration is going to look like neon
so the sodium cation is smaller and what
does that tell us well if this one right
over here let me circle it like this if
this is smaller and we have similar
charges on top you have a plus 1 and a
negative 1 on top that's the charges
between the two ions but now you have a
smaller radius between the nuclei
because sodium is smaller than rubidium
well as the radius goes down the force
goes up so you're going to have stronger
Coulomb forces in a lattice of sodium
chloride than in a lattice of rubidium
chloride because the force of attraction
is stronger it's going to take more
energy to pull it apart so because of
that you're going to have a higher
higher lattice energy lattice energy for
sodium chloride than rubidium chloride
now let's think about another ionic
compound let's say we were to think
about magnesium fluoride f2 and this is
made up of a magnesium cation that has a
positive 2 charge so 2 plus in in a
lattice with a bunch of fluoride anions
so with a bunch of fluoride anions so
how would the lattice energy of
magnesium fluoride compare to what we
just saw up here so magnesium has a
larger charge
then these cations up here so if you
viewed the charge of magnesium is q1
you're gonna have something larger up
there and that fluoride is a smaller
anion than chloride we can see that if
we look at the periodic table of
elements again fluorine is smaller than
chlorine and so even if you add an
electron to both of them fluoride is
still going to be smaller and magnesium
when you take two electrons off of it
it's going to have the noble gas
configure a lek Tron configuration of
neon but it's going to pull even more on
those that's those second shell
electrons because it has 12 protons
versus sodium only has 11 so what we see
here is not only does magnesium have a
larger positive charge than the sodium
cation does but it's going to be smaller
and the fluoride has a comparable charge
to the chloride but it too is going to
be smaller so we have a larger charge on
top at least for the magnesium and you
have smaller radii for the bottom so in
magnesium fluoride the Coulomb forces
between the ions and the lattice are
even stronger and so the lattice energy
the energy necessary to pull it apart is
going to be higher so out of the three
we just looked at the highest lattice
energy is going to be magnesium fluoride
followed by sodium chloride followed by
rubidium chloride